un mec que j'adore moi je vous dis la
vérité je suis sûr que si je l'appelle
même maintenant voilà il va me répondre
c'est vraiment un mec pour moi c'est
vraiment mon gars sueur il m'a jamais
lâché je l'appelle même parfois quand
j'ai des petits qui galère des petits
moments un peu moins bien c'est booba
jade hormonal
c'est ce soir je sais qui sort son
nouveau single
donc j'ai même envie de la fin de la wii
alors il a mon avis tu sais pas répond à
miami je sais pas je vais l'appeler tout
de suite 5 g après deux chansons pendant
six heures de voir valeo page et me
frémaux b2o voilà vous avez franck
gastambide aussi vous avez non mais on
rêve assure franck gastambide hormis la
garde aussi mais c'est vrai que bon bah
c'est moins évident mais je dirais que
je les adore voilà c'est avec à chaque
fois que je demande un truc il est
présent alors des lois et répond ça va
mon frérot d'amour je disais que je
t'aimais je disais que je t'aimais dans
l'émission j'ai dit que j'étais comme un
ouf parce que ce soit ton nouveau single
5 g qui sort sur les pales forme ça va
mon frérot tu es bien mes amis à mes à
ballon à gaumont ses patronnes pas parce
qu apparemment ça va être
by donnant le président mais ce thème
plus tard et je voulais te dire un truc
j'ai pas encore écouté mon single 5g je
l'attends ce soir jeudi à midi je crois
que je crois qu'une surprise de dons
plus je sais je sais il paraît il mais
il n'a pas voulu me dire ce que c'était
les grecs est une petite surprise y tu
as quitté une petite surprise pour moi
de rouget
je voulais te dire que je t'aime
vraiment fort et je disais tu es un gars
à chaque fois que l'appel et c1 était
vraiment réalité vraiment un fait partie
de mes gars sur et que je t'aime fort
parce que à chaque fois que j'ai besoin
de toi que j'ai besoin d'un truc un
conseil un truc tu me réponds toujours
tu es toujours là tu sais que je t'aime
fort de la piraterie exactement c'est sa
[ __ ] merci mme rey merci mon frère
booba et ce soir minuit puis à 5 g qui
sort et à minuit à minuit
00h01 site envoie un sms j'attends moi
un message t'embrasse très fort ferrero
au thème fort est tombée dexia tu viens
boire je t'embrasse fort sombre histoire
[Applaudissements]
d'embrasser non mais franchement il
paraît qu'ils ma faim ça c'est parce que
c'est là que je me dis qu'il va faire un
cadeau ou dedans et qui m'a fait une
surprise de housses dans son nouveau
single qui sort ce soir à minuit
ça me fait kiffer j'ai hâte de savoir
donc ce soir je vais être à fond voilà
je vous dis il sort sur toutes les
plateformes 5g nouveau single de booba
ce soir à minuit il a été hyper fort
parce qu'il a lancé plein de singles en
fait là des faux bail mais toute la
journée même partout qu'on peut voir il
ya 14 heures il ya 12 heures c'est ça et
en communication cédant est le vrai
single 5 g il sort ce soir à minuit
booba qui embrasse fort et que j'aime
vraiment énormément c'est un super mec